bonjour et merci d'être direct avec nous
sur rt france alors le nombre de cas de
contamination est celui d admission en
réanimation continue d'augmenter en tant
que médecin qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète
le plus c'est effectivement un point
s'il le fait que nos réanimation là
commence à être dans certaines régions
de france à la limite de la saturation
et on sait qu'il y aura un peu de retard
par rapport au nombre de cas qui
augmente l'encontre le moment où le
nombre de cas commencent à augmenter le
moment où les gens arrivent en
réanimation il se passe souvent une ou
deux semaines donc on peut penser que
les semaines qui viennent vont être
difficiles pour faire face justement à
cette deuxième vague le gouvernement a
pris de nouvelles mesures
le couvre-feu mais il faudra patienter
pour en connaître les résultats cette
mesure est elle suffisante pour casser
la chaîne de contamination selon vous
jean le sera a posteriori en tout cas il
fallait passer à des mesures
supplémentaires et ça a été fait la
semaine dernière la situation est
différente par rapport au mois de mars
quand on est obèse mis en place qu'au
film ans parce qu'on sait que ça va
probablement durer donc on peut pas être
aussi radicale que ce qui a été en tout
cas on essaye de pas l'être mais on
n'est pas à l'abri de la nécessité de
renforcer encore les mesures dans
quelques jours alors tous les soirs les
français attendent impatiemment de
connaître justement le nombre de cas de
contamination c'est vrai que
les derniers chiffres la folle un petit
peu la population
quand on parle de 52000 cas de
contamination ces personnes sont
porteuses du virus mais elles sont pas
nécessairement malade un point critique
n'est ce pas oui oui et puis hier quand
même une bonne partie même parmi ceux
qui sont malades qu auront pas besoin
d'aller à l'hôpital et qui vont bien
rire c'est la grande majorité c'est plus
de 95% des gens qui attrapent la commune
qui auront pas besoin d'aller à
l'hôpital
donc il faut pas non plus dramatiser et
je pense que c'est pas une bonne chose
de regarder les chiffres
tous les jours c'est très anxiogène il
faut juste suivre de temps en temps et
puis suivent les consignes surtout alors
pourquoi on a l'impression qu'il ya un
effet de panique notamment le
gouvernement lui-même qui a du mal dans
un communication qu'est ce qui est
différent par rapport au printemps est
ce que c'est plus inquiétant ou sale et
moi on est à peu près un tiers de ce
qu'on a connu au plus haut de la
première vague donc c'est plus
inquiétant pour l'instant je pensais
surtout la répétition on sait pas qu'on
arrête deux fois de suite un tel ou tel
événement en tout cas on pensait pouvoir
l'éviter
ça a l'air d'être le cas et par hier les
chiffres qu'on comme beaucoup augmenté
la semaine dernière depuis une dizaine
de jours c'est vraiment sans comparaison
avec ce qu'on a connu jusqu'à la
mi-octobre donc on comprend que que ça
s'accélère aussi en terme de
communication du gouvernement
justement le les chiffres qui sont qui
sont aujourd'hui à dévoiler comme je
disais sont assez importants c'est aussi
peut-être à cause des tests puisque
aujourd'hui on est beaucoup plus de gens
alors qu'au début de de la première
vague
on n'était pas capable d'assurer cet
aspect là oui c'est pour ça que le
nombre de nouveaux cas et probablement
pas l'information la plus importante
l'information importante c'est le nombre
de patients qui ont besoin d'aller à
l'hôpital et parmi ceux là ceux qui ont
besoin de la réanimation
parce que ça c'est quelque chose qui est
un peu indépendant de la disponibilité
des tests les gens qui ont besoin de
venir à l'hôpital y viennent à l'hôpital
et dans les tests non c'est pas parce
qu'on a plus d'accès aux tests qu'on a
plus de gens en réanimation cela serait
venu en réanimation même avec un ou deux
tests limité alors pour parler justement
de ses services de réanimation on sait
que les hôpitaux étaient surchargés au
début de l'épidémie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui au point de vue de
l'organisation les hôpitaux savent mieux
gérer la situation qu'elle est justement
les choses qui sont mises en place dans
votre hôpital à rennes alors il ya
plusieurs choses qu'on sait mieux on
sait mieux comment activer le niveau au
dessus si on avait besoin en cas
d'admission de patience qui est pas
encore vraiment le cas dans l'ouest de
la france mais qui pourrait arriver on
saura comment faire et puis on sait
aussi mieux comment soigner les patients
on sait les traitements qui fonctionne
ce qui fonctionne pas on sait comment
administrer l'oxygène le plus
efficacement possible
donc ça ça va être notre faveur cela va
nous permettre aux allemands de garder
les patients moins longtemps et de les
améliorer plus rapidement la dernière
question professeur tad 20 est ce que le
coc u19 est toujours aussi dangereux
qu'au début de son apparition est ce qu
il a buté est ce que voilà ce sont les
mêmes cas graves que l'on observe
aujourd'hui en service de réanimation
ça ressemble énormément et il a
effectivement but et sert virus qui mute
mais les virologues qui connaissent très
bien le sujet puisqu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de mutation qui soit très
déterminante et les réanimateurs qui
voit les patients disent que c'est pas
très différent je pense pas qu'il soit
différent de ce qu'il était au web mars
merci beaucoup en tout cas pierre
tattevin d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
la société de pathologie infectieuse de
langue française et professeur de
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes